get ready to pay more this winter to
stay warm the government sounding the
alarm that prices could go up
drastically that's right and they could
go even higher if the temperature
continues to drop
today the government announced residents
heating bill could jump this year by as
much as 54 percent compared to 2020 the
forecast predicts a colder winter which
means more people will likely burn more
fuel to keep warm southwest gas sharing
some energy tips to help first set the
daytime thermostat between 65 to 68
degrees and if health permits lower that
at night also change the air filters on
a regular base
finally seal leaks and cracks around
doors windows and other openings raul
david with bulldog air conditioning and
heating repairs says regular maintenance
is key the biggest factor that we do to
helping equipment run efficiently is air
flow so if a filter is not doing its job
by letting the right amount of air clean
air through the system
the cool than the heating doesn't matter
airflow is what we need to do first
david says 20 percent of your power bill
is air conditioning with the proper
attention he says that number can be
reduced saving a customer about 25
percent in costs
well southwest gas tells us that the
company passes the cost of gas straight
through to the customer now those rates
are associated with disturb with
distribute distributing natural gas
prices which can change due to market
fluctuation